mike congratulations you made it to the
final three that is an amazing
achievement i hope you're proud of
yourself
how are you feeling now that the season
has wrapped up
i'm very happy um with the results in
terms of marianne winning survivor
however i would have liked that one but
if i had to lose to somebody i'm glad it
was marion she's a wonderful person and
quite frankly a deserving winner
i'm fine i'm happy life is good um i
mean i was on the greatest
reality
uh tv show in the history of tv and i
came out second in a game that i've
admired and watched for 21 years
you know it don't get better than this
no it's truly a dream come true and in
the final episode you had this beautiful
moment that was also a dream come true
during that challenge you ended up
winning the puzzle which was amazing
how were you feeling in that moment
because i knew lindsay had the advantage
did you think you were going to be able
to pull it off
you know you don't know how you're going
to do in the challenge until it starts
everybody
thinks they can win a challenge you
never say i'm not going to win the
challenge but when i'm going against a
lindsay with an advantage and jonathan's
been a challenge beast
i felt the only advantage i had there
was that not only was a physical portion
but there was a puzzle portion so i knew
that i couldn't keep up with them with
lindsey and jonathan during the physical
portion but i knew that once i got to
the puzzle i would do a lot better but
then i thought i have to worry about
marianne who was probably a great puzzle
maker um
but once i got to the puzzle and i was
a little bit behind i started seeing the
puzzle just come to come to me and i saw
the lines very easily it was one of
those things where i just saw it coming
together and i was able to pull it out
do you expect to win probably not
especially at that point against
considering my gone against but once i
won it was overwhelming it was surreal
it was a bucket list item
and it was at you know the final five
i'm so happy for you that you got to
have that moment because there's nothing
quite like it um so if we fast forward
to that tribal council
you give your idol to marianne so can
you tell us more about that decision
well the decision was not that hard to
me because
um
lindsay had wanted the idol to save her
but lindsay had
was wasn't an alliance with omar alma
was trying to get me out with the
nullifier i love lindsay as a person but
that that point of the game i really
felt that lindsay was gonna be our
biggest competition going in into the
finals so
i couldn't give it to her and
maybe i'm using it for a reason but she
never told me about almost nullified
which proved to me she was loyal to omar
and not me
on the other side of the coins i went to
marianne to help me vote omar out and i
proved that by you utilizing the
nullifier and i promised marianne if she
did work with me i would give her my
idol i thought that would accomplish two
things it would it would show that the
jury that i was trying to be honorable
and keep my word also i really felt
it didn't matter marion wasn't on the
chopping block it was either going to be
lindsay or jonathan giving it to her
made a
a jury move and a move of loyalty to
marian where she knew that i was on her
side so it was quite easy i never
thought
other than to give it to her
so later in the episode you had another
wonderful moment the fire making
challenge and for someone who makes a
living of putting fires out the fire you
made was huge so how confident were you
going into the fire making challenge i
knew i could make fire
but as in anything in life nothing's a
sure thing jonathan was the fire beast
throughout the season he made every fire
at camp everyone's oh we get jonathan to
make the fight jonathan's great at this
jonathan's great at that and jonathan
was also very confident and as you see
through the episode
i knew i was going fire they just felt
that they had to put the best person to
take me out which was jonathan
was i confident in beating jonathan no
was i confident that i can make a fire
yes so once i saw looked over and saw
the type of wood and there was a soft
wood i really felt that it would burn
quickly i just needed to create heat
quickly with the with the corn husks get
them burning hot get a couple little
sticks burned and once i saw those
burning i started teeping which created
air which i knew would make it rise and
it was just science after that it was
just i knew they would take off
it was a massive fire and speaking of
heat at tribal council let's talk about
the final tribal council because
no one really knows what it's like to
have people just totally grill you there
is nothing quite like it in life so tell
me about your experience doing final
tribal and is there anything you wish
you did differently
um
final tribal was a tough one because
you answer for your sins
and sometimes it's tough to answer for
your sins and
it's even tougher when sometimes you
don't think you create sins that you
should have to answer to i was wrong
going in there um
they brought up points that i really
didn't give much thought to i looked at
the playing survivor as a game a game
like poker where if i bluff if i have a
pair of deuces and i take out somebody
with a full house they may be mad that
they lost but they're not mad at me
because i told a lie which is a bluff
that they would just be mad at
themselves and then we'd be okay
afterwards
um sometimes that that's not the case
the jury brought that up
at some points i agree with them some
points i didn't but i realized at that
point it didn't matter what i thought
the perception to them was that there
were times i lied when i said i was
playing honorable but i always felt in
any game we play
part of the rules especially especially
survivor
the game is lying and beast being
deceptive if you don't do that you can't
win
my mistake was i thought that was a
given i shouldn't have and i based my
game on honor and integrity and they
pointed out some of those flaws which
ultimately hurt me
mm-hmm
you're right as you know it's tough
being in there coming at you coming at
you coming at you
because it's hours people the viewers
don't realize you're sitting there for
hours so i have respect for anyone who
is able to sit through that
yes you know how long it is we're there
for a long time
and
and and god bless the juries they they
take their they take their role very
seriously and if they feel they have a
point they're going to keep pounding
again until you either submit or you
admit to it
a hundred percent it's it's a weird part
of the game where you have these
relationships with people but you have
to accept that they're going to ask you
tough questions um and i think that what
made watching you so great is you really
invested in building relationships with
people you had a lot of open and genuine
conversations so
what do you feel like you personally are
taking away from your survivor
experience
the biggest thing i can say i take away
from my experience is getting to know
people
whether they were older
different cultures
learning how they lived and
appreciating it respecting it
and realizing
i'm a guy from jersey
johnson's a guy from alabama marian's a
girl from canada
um romeo is a guy and as different as we
really all are whether it be how we look
what religions we're all kind of the
same and i've agree i've created
friendships i have for the rest of my
life from people from all walks of life
just because i stood i took the time to
understand where they were coming from
and quite frankly they did the same for
me because i'm at face value they may
look at me and say i could never be a
friend with this guy he doesn't look
like but once they got to know me they
realized i'm just like them and i
realized they were just like me so that
was the best thing i i took out of
survivor
i think after watching you out there and
just being so genuine with who you are
everyone will want to be your friend
mike
i loved it i really love getting to meet
everybody out there
and we loved meeting you as viewers and
i want to say thank you so much for just
going out there being yourself i loved
watching you play and thank you for
chatting today and i truly i wish you
all the best i can't wait to see what's
next for you
thank you all right so you know it's a
pleasure is mine and i'm a big fan i
really enjoyed you during your season oh
man thank you oh my we have to get
together sometime we can see each other
over a drink or something absolutely
you